et bien bienvenue à la fouillouse thècle
en bon français donc ce sont toutes les
nouvelles technologies rapporté à
l'agroalimentaire 93 exposants sont
présents ici à cet événement unique en
france je vous propose d'aller faire un
tour sur les stands dans ses allées un
peu aseptisé difficile de trouver
quelque chose à se mettre sous la dent
nous avons cependant trouver peut-être
l'alimentation de cette fin du 21e
siècle une poudre à base d'éléments
végétaux
bonjour alors dites moi de quoi
s'agit-il alors vite à l'insee des repas
prêts à consommer qui vont être optimisé
une triche finalement c'est à dire fait
pour être le meilleur possible pour
votre santé vous permettre d'avoir un
super niveau de tonus très bien vous
alimentez vous nous fait goûter
alors bien sûr avec plaisir au plat et
donc il ya plus que à ajouter de l'eau
dans la bouteille
on va goûter donc c'est une version free
rouge et une base avoine et nous vous
reconnaîtrez investi aux fruits rouges
très bien bah écoutez pour manger sur le
pouce et l'idéal j'imagine on va
continuer notre visite et merci encore
[Musique]
la grande tendance cette année dans ce
salon c'est la traçabilité
vous savez ces applications qui
permettent aux particuliers de voir les
ingrédients qui sont dans les produits
qu'ils achètent
mais nous ce qui a retenu notre
attention c'est la gestion du gaspillage
françois vallet et dans la société
commerciaux qui gère les invendus donc
françois dites moi un peu quel est le
principe de votre société
nous on mêle les nouvelles techno au
sein même de nos solutions pour aider
les entreprises à valoriser leurs
invendus
par exemple lorsque l'on fait les
collectes d'invendus pour les
redistribuer aux associations on a un
système de traçabilité numérique qui
permet exactement de tracer la
marchandise de savoir et bien que cette
marchandise elle parle elle part de tel
magasin elle arrive à telle association
françois jour merci pour nous la visite
s'arrête maintenant mais je vous propose
revenir ici demain c'est ouvert au grand
public jusqu'à 18 heures une façon pour
vous de découvrir toutes ces innovations